my spidey sense is tingling way off the
charts Clifford Duvall
I'm a big fan
the fastest man alive against the
fastest mind alive so this is gonna be
my episode 7 video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet and
we'll be talking a little bit about
what's going on in the next couple of
episodes around the crossover because
the story of the crossover will be
separate from what's been happening on
the flash this season there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video on him
a new winner at the end of this so
probably one of the best episodes of the
season so far mostly because it's a
mythology episode and those always tend
to do the best like deep cuts from the
comics so top 10 WTF comic book Easter
eggs there's all kinds of references to
pop culture stuff too like Jack the
Ripper
but number 10 the thinker and his wife
explained what was happening back during
the events of season 1 the particle
accelerator explosion this just confirms
my theory after seeing the trailer last
week now I saw the protest sign so I
just naturally assumed because of the
speedforce effect with the liquid rising
that this was happening with the
original particle accelerator explosion
so you get an explainer for what the
thinking cap is why he needs it what the
thinkers been doing this whole time he's
just a regular college history professor
he keeps talking about how people are
doomed to repeat history and his wife is
also a professor at the University she's
like a more hardcore version of Cisco
given a couple more years like Cisco's
an engineer but he doesn't spend a lot
of time engineering things nowadays
because he's been doing mostly vibe
stuff but the whole idea is is that
number 9 he's going to use the thinking
cap built by his wife to expand his
brains processing power that will give
him the ability to solve all of
humanity's problems so this is actually
a really important idea because you see
the slow descent throughout the
flashbacks as things progressed he
slowly loses the ability to walk he
develops advanced ALS he's not a villain
but he gets so stuck on his plan to make
the world better and solve all these
problems like it becomes addictive for
him solving problems that you start to
see through his actions he becomes a
villain like the way he manipulates
people that's really where you get into
villain territory because all great
villains usually start out wanting to do
something good but number 8 Barry and
Joe pick up in the moments after last
week's episode
questioning them in present day they
seem like a totally normal couple and
you sort of get this cat-and-mouse
strangers on a train Hitchcock thing
going on where Barry is just obsessed he
knows that something is up but he
doesn't know how to prove it I was so
happy with the way they ended the
episode like they let you know exactly
what the ticking clock is going to be on
everyone else finding out about what's
going on it's not gonna be four episodes
of Barry trying to convince the group
but here's where we get to a lot of our
pop-culture references they name drop
blind swordsman turns out Harrison wells
on earth too is a big fan I love the way
that sometimes Cisco starts talking
about movies and it turns out Harrison
wells is also a big fan too like they
actually share a lot in common even
though they're sort of like the DC
version of The Odd Couple but the
interesting thing about Wells is like he
steps out of the bushes after they get
out of the house was it him did you guys
find anything out I'm wondering if the
thinker is going to start using wells
identity against him like remember we
had the flashback to evil eobard thawne
Harrison wells we know that he confessed
to the murder of Barry's mother at the
end of season one meaning that Harrison
wells is a fugitive on earth one so just
remember that Harrison wells being in
public is a really bad idea but number
seven Barry stills the mug they tested
there's no metahuman DNA the way that
thinker explained that later in the
episode is that he's just thought ahead
so he found a way to mask his metahuman
DNA because he is a metahuman he said
that the lightning bolt the struck Barry
also gave him his powers you know in
combination with the thinking cap it
just sort of supercharged his brain but
that big flashback scene was probably
one of the most fun parts of the episode
they actually use footage right out of
the pilot episode so Barry runs off to
get irises purse which is why he doesn't
hear any of this DeVoe stuff happening
here so they're still well within Canon
they haven't broken any of their own
continuity or anything like that but
isn't it so funny when Harrison wells
says I expect great things from you to
vote I can't wait to see some of the
contributions that you'll offer to the
world like he knows what the thinker is
going to become the way that he said
that to felicity back during the flash
season one he manipulated everyone to
get back home but also to tangentially
create all those new metas number six
was the Spidey
since shout out just because we got the
felicity Hulk shout out a couple weeks
ago meaning that Marvel Comics is
actually a pretty big thing in the DC
Universe but a couple of weeks ago in
the first episode this season they did
the Stan Lee excelsior line so it's
almost like Marvel Comics inside this
universe of earth one is just as big as
Marvel Comics in the real world in our
lives but number five Davos starts
outmaneuvering Barry he goes to captain
Singh he starts manipulating Barry's
real life to try and keep him at bay for
a little while remember a couple of
weeks ago they talked about how he was
going to learn to Vosges identity ahead
of schedule like the thinker has planned
out what his and Barry's encounters are
gonna look like when they'll actually
fight each other how that'll go down
like he's thought of every conceivable
outcome based on the way that Barry
thinks so the obvious solution to that
is Barry changing the way that he
tackles problems at least in the short
term but now captain Singh is on his ass
Annie's been suspended for two weeks so
I know there were a lot of questions
about the picture how did she get that
of him when he was using SuperSpeed so
number four I think the idea is is that
Barry is just not used to your usual B&E
he's not reverse-flash
so like when the reverse-flash broke
into his parents house and killed his
mother
he blurred his face the entire time and
Barry did not do that when he broke into
the thinker's house so just blame that
on the fact that Barry is not used to
being a criminal which is a good thing
it would be weird if he were really good
at being a bad person like he doesn't
think like a psychopath would the way
the thinker is starting to think like
the smarter he gets the more his body
degenerates the more he gets really cold
and calculated about it but you know
that twist at the end where he's like
I'm gonna let him get married because
what Slauson pain without love and
you're his wife gives him that nice
touch on the hand like oh that's so
sweet
so they want to differentiate him from
other flash villains by showing you that
he's not a murderer Machin likes avatar
was number three the möbius chair he
learns that his mind is slowly killing
his body so they have to develop a way
to halt that process it's basically an
advanced version of ALS the reason why
the writers are probably doing that is
to put a ticking clock on him like he
has a sense of urgency about the plan
he's trying to bring to fruition
otherwise he would just have unlimited
time like why not take 50 years to bring
my plan about so based on the timing of
the flashback the thinker basically has
till the end of this season and then his
body is going to die like he's gonna die
no matter what so he needs to complete
his task before that happens and they
just called this special space that he's
in the vortex chamber you get the
explainer for how he plugs into it like
the top of his head literally comes off
in nodes plug into his brain which is
just coursing with energy just to show
you how powerful he is and you also get
a couple funny shout outs during this
whole process too like he's like I want
to make the world a better place
most metahumans get their powers and
they want to rob banks or create
tornadoes there's just a reference to
back during season 1 when this was
happening to the original version of
whether wizard but number 2 Wally West
comes back from Blue Valley with a major
star oh shout out fighting a starfish
from outer space so it's like wow okay
that's actually a pretty big deal maybe
they'll reference that in an episode
maybe he's just aligned a dialogue so
that almost makes it sound like he was
doing Titans related stuff but within
the arrow verse I know there's a lot of
questions about the actual Titan show
he's just talking about stuff that
happened in Blue Valley in the Titans TV
show is taking place in Bludhaven so
completely different place cisco dub
sims the thinker officially and then of
course number one is sort of like his
overarching plan so he's got all these
bus metahumans he's creating some of
them to keep the flash busy but he's
also using their powers in concert so
that as he explained he can enlighten
the rest of the world so if you remember
the geoff johns run he was sort of
converting keystone city to this digital
presence like everybody got plugged into
these nodes they might actually be doing
a version of that because they did that
at the end when you see them plug into
his brain we might actually wind up
getting this comic book panel with the
nodes plugged into Flash's brain later
this season in that wound up turning
into this big matrix type story so we'll
see like this is still a physical room
they just call it the vortex room
because that's where the Mobius chair is
but for now it does seem like they're
being fairly accurate to that Geoff
Johns run you may be the fastest man
alive but I'm the fastest mind alive so
it's like a very Sherlock moment
where he's saying the game is afoot so
now it's like Barry and Cisco are
Sherlock and Watson they have to solve
this crime but it is gonna get dark so
what'll happen is is they'll probably be
some more trailers for the crossover and
obviously I got some more Justice League
and flash point movie stuff to post this
week but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Weezy please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there'll be a new round when I post new
DC you can click here for my Justice
League deleted scenes and alternate post
credits video and you can click here to
learn all about Legion of super-heroes
and Brainiac coming to the DC TV
universe thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight